This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is going to sound like a stand-up comedy bit, but I was on my way to the airport recently, and I needed the confirmation email from my flight so I could get my boarding pass. So I pulled up my phone and I typed in some keywords into the search bar of the mail program. I started with the airline I thought I was taking, but that search pulled up mailing list promotions and old flights, and I know if I search long enough and hard enough I could eventually find it, but the thing is, by now I'm at the airport, and I just have this naive conviction that searching should be better and easier.
This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is going to sound like a stand-up comedy bit, but I was on my way to the airport recently, and I needed the confirmation email from my flight so I could get my boarding pass. So I pulled up my phone and I typed in some keywords into the search bar of the mail program. I started with the airline I thought I was taking, but that search pulled up mailing list promotions and old flights, and I know if I search long enough and hard enough I could eventually find it, but the thing is, by now I'm at the airport, and I just have this naive conviction that searching should be better and easier.|||这里是“99%隐形”播客。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这听起来可能像个单口喜剧的段子，但不久前我在去机场的路上，需要找到航班的确认邮件来打印登机牌。于是我掏出手机，在邮件程序的搜索栏里输入了一些关键词。我先是输入了我以为自己搭乘的航空公司，但那个搜索结果弹出来的全是邮件列表促销和过去的航班。我深知，只要我搜得够久、够深，最终肯定能找到它。但关键是，我现在已经到机场了，我只是有一种天真的坚信，那就是搜索本该更出色、更简便才对。
But I often come up empty. There are days when I feel like I've control effed up my life into oblivion and I'll never easily find the email I need, much less old photos and documents on my hard drive. The good news is, I'm not alone. Adam Rogers feels this particular pain too. You know, you think emails are problems, so try to find a slack you once wrote. You know, try to find it tweet, try to search for a photo on Flickr or Instagram, Pinterest. Like I dare you. Adam's a senior tech correspondent at Insider.
But I often come up empty. There are days when I feel like I've control effed up my life into oblivion and I'll never easily find the email I need, much less old photos and documents on my hard drive. The good news is, I'm not alone. Adam Rogers feels this particular pain too. You know, you think emails are problems, so try to find a slack you once wrote. You know, try to find it tweet, try to search for a photo on Flickr or Instagram, Pinterest. Like I dare you. Adam's a senior tech correspondent at Insider.|||但我常常一无所获。有时我觉得自己把生活搞得一团糟，根本无法轻松找到需要的邮件，更不用说硬盘里的老照片和旧文档了。好消息是，我并不孤单。亚当·罗杰斯也感受过这种独特的痛苦。你知道的，如果你觉得找邮件就是个问题，那去试着找一条你曾经写过的 Slack 消息吧。去找一条推文，或者在 Flickr、Instagram、Pinterest 上搜索一张照片。我敢你这么试试。亚当是《Insider》网站的资深科技记者。
He's been thinking and writing about what's known in the industry as search. For the last decade, people have been grumbling about not being able to find things online, both in our private data and on the public web. I would say to people, I think search sucks and other people would say, oh my God, it really does. For Adam, this takes for this go beyond me not being able to find that one email.
He's been thinking and writing about what's known in the industry as search. For the last decade, people have been grumbling about not being able to find things online, both in our private data and on the public web. I would say to people, I think search sucks and other people would say, oh my God, it really does. For Adam, this takes for this go beyond me not being able to find that one email.|||过去十年来，他一直在思考和撰写有关业内所谓的“搜索”的文章。无论是在我们的私人数据中，还是在公开的网络上，人们一直在抱怨无法在网上找到想要的东西。我会对别人说，我觉得搜索太烂了，而其他人则会附和说：“天哪，确实如此。”对亚当来说，这种情况已经不仅仅是我找不到那一封邮件那么简单了。
I will tell you, I'll tell you a personal story. It's one of the ways that I started to think about this. My grandmother was a professor of library science at UC Berkeley. When Adam's grandmother was alive, she lived in a small apartment. Every wall was filled with rows and rows of books. She was a librarian. They were really well organized. The books held all the knowledge that Adam's grandmother wanted to access.
I will tell you, I'll tell you a personal story. It's one of the ways that I started to think about this. My grandmother was a professor of library science at UC Berkeley. When Adam's grandmother was alive, she lived in a small apartment. Every wall was filled with rows and rows of books. She was a librarian. They were really well organized. The books held all the knowledge that Adam's grandmother wanted to access.|||我来跟你讲个故事，一个我开始思考这个问题的个人经历。我的祖母曾是加州大学伯克利分校的图书馆学教授。在亚当的祖母还活着的时候，她住在一个小公寓里。每一面墙上都摆满了密密麻麻的书。她是一名图书管理员。这些书被整理得井井有条。书里蕴含着亚当的祖母想要获取的所有知识。
It was arranged by topic and author complete with important search tools. Notes and tabs stuck into all the various volumes that she could reference when looking to pull up some tidbit of information. Adam was charmed by the whole thing. But as she got older and was a little bit less coherent, she didn't remember stuff as well. And the notes became less and less coherent. And I find that terrifying. Adam's grandmother had built a working search function, and it failed. All the same millions of pages of information were still there, mining the walls, but she
It was arranged by topic and author complete with important search tools. Notes and tabs stuck into all the various volumes that she could reference when looking to pull up some tidbit of information. Adam was charmed by the whole thing. But as she got older and was a little bit less coherent, she didn't remember stuff as well. And the notes became less and less coherent. And I find that terrifying. Adam's grandmother had built a working search function, and it failed. All the same millions of pages of information were still there, mining the walls, but she|||书籍按主题和作者分类排列，还配有重要的搜索工具。各种卷册里塞满了笔记和标签，当她想要调取某些琐碎的信息时就可以参考。亚当对这一切着迷不已。但随着她年纪渐长，思维也变得有些不够连贯，记性大不如前。那些笔记也变得越来越语无伦次。我觉得这太可怕了。亚当的祖母曾建立起一套行之有效的搜索功能，但它失效了。成百上千页的信息依然原封不动地贴在墙壁上，但她却……
couldn't access this archive of knowledge. According to Adam, the same thing could be happening when we search for anything on our computers. More and more, we outsource our information, our personal information, and our autobiographical memories. We outsource that more and more to digital media now. Not just the sum total of human knowledge, but also our own photos, emails, and memories stored in the cloud. As we put more and more of that somewhere else besides our own heads, search becomes more and more of a existential crisis, not just an annoying thing where I can't find the email with my confirmation number in it.
couldn't access this archive of knowledge. According to Adam, the same thing could be happening when we search for anything on our computers. More and more, we outsource our information, our personal information, and our autobiographical memories. We outsource that more and more to digital media now. Not just the sum total of human knowledge, but also our own photos, emails, and memories stored in the cloud. As we put more and more of that somewhere else besides our own heads, search becomes more and more of a existential crisis, not just an annoying thing where I can't find the email with my confirmation number in it.|||无法再访问这座知识的宝库了。亚当认为，当我们用电脑搜索任何东西时，同样的事情也可能正在发生。我们越来越多地将我们的信息、个人信息以及自传体记忆外包出去。如今，我们越来越依赖数字媒体来承载这些内容。不仅是人类知识的总和，还包括我们自己的照片、电子邮件以及存储在云端的记忆。随着我们将越来越多的内容存放在大脑之外的其他地方，搜索越来越演变成一场生存危机，而不仅仅是“找不到带有确认号的邮件”这种烦心事。
We begin to potentially literally forget ourselves. Our ability to search and retrieve information at our whim feels like one of the most important developments of the digital age. So how do we get to a point where it feels like search is failing us? And how do we fix it before it's too late? Today the word search sort of feels synonymous with the word Google, but I think it's actually one of the oldest design problems in the world. From the time humans started writing stuff down,
We begin to potentially literally forget ourselves. Our ability to search and retrieve information at our whim feels like one of the most important developments of the digital age. So how do we get to a point where it feels like search is failing us? And how do we fix it before it's too late? Today the word search sort of feels synonymous with the word Google, but I think it's actually one of the oldest design problems in the world. From the time humans started writing stuff down,|||我们甚至可能开始从字面意义上遗忘我们自己。我们随心所欲地搜索和检索信息的能力，似乎是数字时代最重要的发展之一。那么，我们是怎么走到这一步的——感觉搜索正在让我们失望？我们又该如何在为时已晚之前修复它呢？如今，“搜索”这个词感觉有点成了“Google”的同义词，但我认为它其实是世界上最古老的设计难题之一。从人类开始记录文字的那一刻起，
the struggle has been how to organize it all so that its contents wouldn't be lost in the stacks. Search has always been an attempt to fix that problem. I think for our purposes here, it does make a lot of sense to think of search as a designed experience. It wasn't just walking into a library and wandering around. Ever since, you know, the priest who ran the libraries at Alexandria knew which scrolls went in which cubby hole or however they did it.
the struggle has been how to organize it all so that its contents wouldn't be lost in the stacks. Search has always been an attempt to fix that problem. I think for our purposes here, it does make a lot of sense to think of search as a designed experience. It wasn't just walking into a library and wandering around. Ever since, you know, the priest who ran the libraries at Alexandria knew which scrolls went in which cubby hole or however they did it.|||人们就在苦苦挣扎，如何将它们全部组织起来，以免内容在浩瀚的书库中迷失。搜索一直以来都是为了解决这个问题而做出的尝试。我认为就我们目前的讨论而言，将搜索视为一种被设计出来的体验是非常有道理的。它绝不仅仅是走进图书馆然后四处闲逛。从古至今，亚历山大图书馆的管理员祭司们就知道哪卷羊皮纸该放在哪个格子，无论他们当时是怎么做的。
And leading up through the DeSple system or library of congress numbers, these things are search. These things are what makes search possible. Long before we could search for things online, Google was essentially a person, a reference librarian. If you wanted to find something on say, growing vegetables, you could go to the gardening or farming sections of the library, but in the thousands of books in that huge section,
And leading up through the DeSple system or library of congress numbers, these things are search. These things are what makes search possible. Long before we could search for things online, Google was essentially a person, a reference librarian. If you wanted to find something on say, growing vegetables, you could go to the gardening or farming sections of the library, but in the thousands of books in that huge section,|||再到后来的杜威十进分类法或国会图书馆分类号，这些东西就是搜索。正是这些东西让搜索成为可能。早在我们能够在线搜索之前，Google 本质上就是一个活生生的人，一个参考咨询馆员。如果你想找关于种植蔬菜之类的资料，你可以去图书馆的园艺或农业区，但在那个巨大区域的数千本书中，
you'd quickly get overwhelmed. That's where reference librarians and archivists come in. They take your topic and help you narrow it down even further, applying their own nuanced knowledge and specialized training to help you search better and find exactly what you're looking for. That's how search operated for centuries by topic mediated by human to human interaction. And it worked pretty well. Good evening, Dr. Bush. Well, I good evening, Ed. But eventually, this easy flow of search hit a snag.
you'd quickly get overwhelmed. That's where reference librarians and archivists come in. They take your topic and help you narrow it down even further, applying their own nuanced knowledge and specialized training to help you search better and find exactly what you're looking for. That's how search operated for centuries by topic mediated by human to human interaction. And it worked pretty well. Good evening, Dr. Bush. Well, I good evening, Ed. But eventually, this easy flow of search hit a snag.|||你很快就会感到无所适从。这就是参考咨询馆员和档案管理员发挥作用的地方。他们接收你的主题，并帮你进一步缩小范围，运用他们细致入微的知识和专业训练来帮你更好地搜索，并准确找到你想要的东西。几个世纪以来，搜索就是这样运作的：通过人与人之间的互动来对主题进行中介。而且它运行得相当不错。晚上好，布什博士。嗯，我，晚上好，埃德。但最终，这种顺畅的搜索流程遇到了瓶颈。
In the mid-1940s, the snag was highlighted by an American engineer named Venever Bush. Well, sir, I've known you a number of years, and last week, I managed to mispronounce Vannever and I apologize. Well you've got plenty of company there Ed most everyone must pronounce it. I think the record was held by one postmaster who managed to pronounce it from four different ways and of course one of you. Dr. Bush. At the time Vannever was convinced that problems with search were
In the mid-1940s, the snag was highlighted by an American engineer named Venever Bush. Well, sir, I've known you a number of years, and last week, I managed to mispronounce Vannever and I apologize. Well you've got plenty of company there Ed most everyone must pronounce it. I think the record was held by one postmaster who managed to pronounce it from four different ways and of course one of you. Dr. Bush. At the time Vannever was convinced that problems with search were|||20世纪40年代中期，美国工程师万内瓦尔·布什（Vannevar Bush）指出了这一瓶颈。呃，先生，我认识您好几年了，上周我竟然把万内瓦尔的名字读错了，我为此道歉。哦，埃德，你可不孤单，几乎所有人都会读错。我记得纪录保持者是一位邮政局长，他竟然能把这个名字读出四种不同的发音，当然其中一种就是你的发音。布什博士。当时，万内瓦尔确信，搜索方面的问题正在
hindering human progress. He pointed to Mendel's ideas on genetics, for example. These ideas were lost for an entire generation, he said, because they were buried in the avalanche of newer research. There was no efficient way for people to parse through all that information. But Vennyver was a big believer in the potential of machines. The analytical machine, which will supplement a man's thinking methods, which will think for it, will have his great effect on his grasp of the world and his access to daughter and so on, his manipulation of it.
hindering human progress. He pointed to Mendel's ideas on genetics, for example. These ideas were lost for an entire generation, he said, because they were buried in the avalanche of newer research. There was no efficient way for people to parse through all that information. But Vennyver was a big believer in the potential of machines. The analytical machine, which will supplement a man's thinking methods, which will think for it, will have his great effect on his grasp of the world and his access to daughter and so on, his manipulation of it.|||阻碍人类的进步。他以孟德尔的遗传学思想为例。他说，这些思想整整一代人都失传了，因为它们被淹没在了更新研究的雪崩之中。当时人们没有高效的方法来解析所有这些信息。但万内瓦尔坚信机器的潜力。分析机将补充人类的思考方式，为人类代为思考，它将在人类对世界的掌握、对数据的获取以及对数据的操控方面产生巨大的影响。
He will have his great effect in that way, as the invention of the machine way back took the load off of men by giving them mechanical power instead of the power of their muscles. So in 1945, Venevier took to the page and dreamed up an imaginary futuristic solution to the problem of search, a machine called Memex. The Memex would make search easier. It would look like a desk. There'd be a keyboard, viewing screens, and storage space for all of human knowledge, as long as it was on microfilm and could fit into a dust drawer.
He will have his great effect in that way, as the invention of the machine way back took the load off of men by giving them mechanical power instead of the power of their muscles. So in 1945, Venevier took to the page and dreamed up an imaginary futuristic solution to the problem of search, a machine called Memex. The Memex would make search easier. It would look like a desk. There'd be a keyboard, viewing screens, and storage space for all of human knowledge, as long as it was on microfilm and could fit into a dust drawer.|||它会以这种方式发挥巨大作用，就像很久以前机械的发明用机械动力代替肌肉力量，从而减轻了人类的负担一样。因此，在1945年，万内瓦尔通过文字勾勒并构想了一个针对搜索问题的未来主义虚拟解决方案——一台名为 Memex 的机器。Memex 会让搜索变得更容易。它看起来像一张书桌。里面会有键盘、显示屏，以及存储全人类知识的存储空间，只要这些知识被制成缩微胶卷，并且能放进一个抽屉里即可。
On the left side there would be all the information in the universe, and it would all have links, and then on the right side, you would follow those links for the information you wanted. So the search became about connections within what you were looking for. Theoretically, the user could teach the mimics which words were relevant to each other. So if the word culture in one document makes me think of death, I could tell the mimics to connect those two words. Then, when I searched for the word culture, all the documents featuring death that I previously linked
On the left side there would be all the information in the universe, and it would all have links, and then on the right side, you would follow those links for the information you wanted. So the search became about connections within what you were looking for. Theoretically, the user could teach the mimics which words were relevant to each other. So if the word culture in one document makes me think of death, I could tell the mimics to connect those two words. Then, when I searched for the word culture, all the documents featuring death that I previously linked|||左边将是宇宙中的所有信息，它们都会带有链接；然后在右边，你就可以顺着这些链接去寻找你想要的信息。因此，搜索变成了一种关于你所寻找内容内部关联的探索。理论上，用户可以教导 Memex 哪些词语是彼此相关的。所以，如果一份文件中的“文化”一词让我联想到“死亡”，我就可以告诉 Memex 将这两个词连接起来。然后，当我搜索“文化”一词时，我之前链接过的所有包含“死亡”的文件
would show up. I could scroll through all the results by turning a crank. In essence, the mimics user could build their own little analog algorithm for search. The mimics was never built, but Paul Con, someone who wrote a whole book about many of his mimics. Well, in the 1990s, he animated how the Memex might have worked. First, he runs through an encyclopedia, finds an interesting but sketchy article, and leaves it projected.
would show up. I could scroll through all the results by turning a crank. In essence, the mimics user could build their own little analog algorithm for search. The mimics was never built, but Paul Con, someone who wrote a whole book about many of his mimics. Well, in the 1990s, he animated how the Memex might have worked. First, he runs through an encyclopedia, finds an interesting but sketchy-looking article, and leaves it projected.|||都会显示出来。我可以通过转动一个手柄来翻阅所有的搜索结果。从本质上讲，Memex 的用户可以构建他们自己的小型模拟搜索算法。Memex 从未被真正建造出来，但保罗·科恩（Paul Kahn）——一个专门写了一整书关于 Memex 的人。在20世纪90年代，他用动画形式演示了 Memex 的工作原理。首先，他浏览了一部百科全书，找到了一篇有趣但看起来很粗略的文章，并将其保持投影状态。
Next, in a history, he finds another pertinent item and ties the two together. Vinny Verkold this process of linking two keywords together, trail-building. The idea of searching documents not by broad topic, but specific word and then linking related documents together turned out to be right on the mark. About 50 years after Vinnyvar dreamed up the mimics, his ideas about search came to fruition with a little thing called the World Wide Web. a wide web. This mimics-inspired idea of searching by keyword became the new default. We're at searching by topic like you would in a library, is similar to looking through the table of contents of a book. Keyword search is like using the index. It is much more precise, and searching by keyword worked well for a time when you type in a word and get
Next, in a history, he finds another pertinent item and ties the two together. Vinny Verkold this process of linking two keywords together, trail-building. The idea of searching documents not by broad topic, but specific word and then linking related documents together turned out to be right on the mark. About 50 years after Vinnyvar dreamed up the mimics, his ideas about search came to fruition with a little thing called the World Wide Web. a wide web. This mimics-inspired idea of searching by keyword became the new default. We're at searching by topic like you would in a library, is similar to looking through the table of contents of a book. Keyword search is like using the index. It is much more precise, and searching by keyword worked well for a time when you type in a word and get|||接下来，在一部历史书中，他找到了另一个相关的条目，并将两者联系在一起。万内瓦尔将这种把两个关键词联系在一起的过程称为“路径构建”。事实证明，不是按广泛主题、而是按具体单词来搜索文档，然后将相关文档串联起来的想法完全切中要害。在万内瓦尔构想出 Memex 大约50年后，他对搜索的理念随着一个叫做万维网（World Wide Web）的小东西而结出了硕果。这种受 Memex 启发而产生的按关键词搜索的想法成为了新的默认标准。我们处在这样一个阶段：按主题搜索就像在图书馆里找书一样，类似于翻阅一本书的目录。而关键词搜索就像在使用索引。它精确得多，并且按关键词搜索在一段时间内运行良好——当时你输入一个词，就能得到
only a couple of dozen results. But as the digital information space gets bigger and bigger, things begin to evolve and change. In 1993, there were 130, yes, you heard that right, 130 websites on the internet. Three years later, there were over 100,000. So that starts to happen very soon when the World Wide Web becomes something that's more than just an academic,
only a couple of dozen results. But as the digital information space gets bigger and bigger, things begin to evolve and change. In 1993, there were 130, yes, you heard that right, 130 websites on the internet. Three years later, there were over 100,000. So that starts to happen very soon when the World Wide Web becomes something that's more than just an academic,|||区区几十个结果。但随着数字信息空间越来越大，事物开始演变和改变。1993年，互联网上有130个网站——是的，你没听错，130个。三年后，这个数字超过了10万。因此，很快当万维网不再仅仅是一个学术工具，不再仅仅是
more than just the thing that connects all of the physics labs. Doing an online search by keyword was now posing problems because the internet was starting to feel crowded and clunky and the usual ways of searching were feeling outdated. The kind of searches that I might have done on Lexus Nexus are pro quest in that 80s or 90s. These carefully constructed searches
more than just the thing that connects all of the physics labs. Doing an online search by keyword was now posing problems because the internet was starting to feel crowded and clunky and the usual ways of searching were feeling outdated. The kind of searches that I might have done on Lexus Nexus are pro quest in that 80s or 90s. These carefully constructed searches|||连接所有物理实验室的事物时，这种转变就开始发生了。通过关键词进行在线搜索开始暴露出问题，因为互联网开始让人感觉拥挤笨拙，常规的搜索方式也显得过时了。我在80或90年代可能在 LexisNexis 或 ProQuest 上进行的那种搜索。这些精心构建的搜索
were you had to pay per search so you really wanted that one search to work because you couldn't keep doing it because it would cost money. And that felt like a very constructed and constrained experience which brings us to when search, as we know it today, was born. A couple of kids at Stanford come up with another approach to searching, called PageRank, and that becomes the basis for Google.
were you had to pay per search so you really wanted that one search to work because you couldn't keep doing it because it would cost money. And that felt like a very constructed and constrained experience which brings us to when search, as we know it today, was born. A couple of kids at Stanford come up with another approach to searching, called PageRank, and that becomes the basis for Google.|||是按次收费的，所以你真的希望那一次搜索能成功，因为你不能一直搜下去，那是要花钱的。这感觉像是一种非常刻意且受限制的体验，这就把我们带到了我们今天所知的搜索诞生的时刻。斯坦福大学的几个年轻人想出了另一种搜索方法，叫做 PageRank，这就成了 Google 的基础。
Google runs using PageRank. And what PageRank says is, we're going to count And what PageRank says is, we're going to count how many things link to something. The idea behind the PageRank algorithm is not only will your search engine find the site's feature in whatever word you asked for, but it will find the best sites with that word. We're going to say that if something has a lot of links to it, that's a better source of information. That we now prioritize that above things that have the same kind of information in them, but don't have as many links. As the Internet expanded, more and more spammy or irrelevant web pages would come up in search results. PageRank helped filter those out by emphasizing high quality results. A .edu link or anything from the BBC, for example, would rank higher
Google runs using PageRank. And what PageRank says is, we're going to count And what PageRank says is, we're going to count how many things link to something. The idea behind the PageRank algorithm is not only will your search engine find the site's feature in whatever word you asked for, but it will find the best sites with that word. We're going to say that if something has a lot of links to it, that's a better source of information. That we now prioritize that above things that have the same kind of information in them, but don't have as many links. As the Internet expanded, more and more spammy or irrelevant web pages would come up in search results. PageRank helped filter those out by emphasizing high quality results. A .edu link or anything from the BBC, for example, would rank higher|||Google 是利用 PageRank 运行的。PageRank 的核心逻辑是，我们要统计——PageRank 的意思是，我们要计算有多少链接指向某个页面。PageRank 算法背后的理念是：你的搜索引擎不仅能找出包含你所查询词汇的网站，还能找出包含该词汇的“最佳”网站。我们认为，如果一个页面有大量链接指向它，它就是更好的信息来源。我们将优先展示它，而不是那些包含相同信息但链接较少的页面。随着互联网的扩张，越来越多的垃圾或不相关网页会出现在搜索结果中。PageRank 通过强调高质量结果，帮助过滤掉了这些垃圾网页。例如，一个 .edu 链接或来自 BBC 的任何内容，在
in a search result than say in the blog. In part, because many other sites would be linking to the more well-known pages. To me, this is super cool. I love this as an insight, because it turns out that that's the same way that, like, memories are reinforced in the brain. How many times do we go back to them? It's the same way that ants tell each other, there's food over there, but not over there. If an ant walks over the trail and leaves pheromones on it again and again and again, that trail becomes more important to the colony. Pretty soon with the help of PageRank, Google became a verb.
in a search result than say in the blog. In part, because many other sites would be linking to the more well-known pages. To me, this is super cool. I love this as an insight, because it turns out that that's the same way that, like, memories are reinforced in the brain. How many times do we go back to them? It's the same way that ants tell each other, there's food over there, but not over there. If an ant walks over the trail and leaves pheromones on it again and again and again, that trail becomes more important to the colony. Pretty soon with the help of PageRank, Google became a verb.|||搜索结果中的排名会比博客等内容更高。部分原因在于，许多其他网站都会链接到更知名的页面。对我来说，这酷毙了。我非常喜欢这个见解，因为事实证明，这与大脑中强化记忆的方式如出一辙。我们回想起它们的次数有多少？这就像蚂蚁互相传达信息一样：那边有食物，而那边没有。如果一只蚂蚁走过一条小径，并一次又一次地在上面留下信息素，这条小径对整个蚁群来说就会变得更加重要。很快，在 PageRank 的帮助下，Google 变成了一个动词。
And since everybody goes to them, they have statistics on what people search for and how they search for them. So they have this incredible statistical oomph. You them, they have statistics on what people search for and how they search for them So they have this incredible statistical oomph You know, they get billions and billions and billions of searches every day and only about 15% of the searches that they see in a given day Are new that they've never seen before so 85% of the searches that the world does on Google every day are things they've already seen They've seen that search before and they can reproduce it type in in some words, and here's the stuff. Here's access to human knowledge. Google's the biggest, bestest, most innovative website.
And since everybody goes to them, they have statistics on what people search for and how they search for them. So they have this incredible statistical oomph. You them, they have statistics on what people search for and how they search for them So they have this incredible statistical oomph You know, they get billions and billions and billions of searches every day and only about 15% of the searches that they see in a given day Are new that they've never seen before so 85% of the searches that the world does on Google every day are things they've already seen They've seen that search before and they can reproduce it type in in some words, and here's the stuff. Here's access to human knowledge. Google's the biggest, bestest, most innovative website.|||既然所有人都在使用它们，它们就掌握了人们搜索什么以及如何搜索的统计数据。因此，它们拥有这种惊人的统计威力。你知道的，它们每天收到数十亿计的搜索请求，但在某一天所看到的搜索中，只有大约 15% 是它们从未见过的新内容；也就是说，全球每天在 Google 上进行的搜索中，有 85% 都是它们已经见过的内容。它们以前就见过这些搜索，并且能够重现它们——输入一些词语，资料就出来了。这就是获取人类知识的途径。Google 是最大、最好、最具创新性的网站。
Well, I guess search engine in the galaxy. Here's a clip from a TV segment in the early 2000s offering its viewers tips on how to search on Google, the hot news search engine in town. So we're here to pump you up with a few tricks that will bring that power back to your browser. There are seven tricks in total. The first one really easy to do will open up Google here in Mozilla.
Well, I guess search engine in the galaxy. Here's a clip from a TV segment in the early 2000s offering its viewers tips on how to search on Google, the hot news search engine in town. So we're here to pump you up with a few tricks that will bring that power back to your browser. There are seven tricks in total. The first one really easy to do will open up Google here in Mozilla.|||嗯，我猜是银河系里最棒的搜索引擎。这里有一段2000年代初的电视节目剪辑，它向观众提供如何在当时大热的新搜索引擎 Google 上进行搜索的技巧。所以我们在这里为你打打气，分享几个能把这种搜索能力重新带回你浏览器的技巧。总共有七个技巧。第一个非常简单易行，我们在这里的 Mozilla 浏览器中打开 Google。
By the way, they just released a new version of Mozilla at Mozilla.org. They're up to 1.2 now, very, very good browser. I've got a number of things. With Google at our fingertips and the proliferation of search bars on every digital interface, it felt like we had finally made it to the very top of human knowledge. And it felt like not a constrained experience. It felt like, oh, that's done. That's fixed. It works.
By the way, they just released a new version of Mozilla at Mozilla.org. They're up to 1.2 now, very, very good browser. I've got a number of things. With Google at our fingertips and the proliferation of search bars on every digital interface, it felt like we had finally made it to the very top of human knowledge. And it felt like not a constrained experience. It felt like, oh, that's done. That's fixed. It works.|||顺便说一句，他们在 Mozilla.org 上刚发布了 Mozilla 的新版本。他们现在已经升级到 1.2 版本了，非常非常好的浏览器。我有好多东西要说。随着 Google 触手可及，以及每个数字界面上搜索栏的泛滥，我们感觉自己终于登上了人类知识的最巅峰。而且这感觉不再是一种受限制的体验。感觉就像是，哦，这下搞定了。修复好了。它管用了。
In fact, the Google search bar with all of its millions of data points is so good, it changed our expectations of what search is. And today, that's part of the problem. We were all trained very well to think, oh, well, now search bars are just like the Google search bar everywhere. And everywhere I see a search bar, it's going to be just as good as a Google search bar is. And then you try that on Amazon. For many of us, when we type a query into an e-commerce website, we expect that the results
In fact, the Google search bar with all of its millions of data points is so good, it changed our expectations of what search is. And today, that's part of the problem. We were all trained very well to think, oh, well, now search bars are just like the Google search bar everywhere. And everywhere I see a search bar, it's going to be just as good as a Google search bar is. And then you try that on Amazon. For many of us, when we type a query into an e-commerce website, we expect that the results|||事实上，拥有数百万个数据点的 Google 搜索栏是如此出色，以至于它改变了我们对“搜索是什么”的期望。而今天，这也是问题的一部分。我们都被很好地训练成了一种思维定式：哦，现在到处都是像 Google 那样的搜索栏了。我看到的每一个搜索栏，应该都和 Google 搜索栏一样好用。然后你在亚马逊上试一下。对我们许多人来说，当我们在电商网站上输入查询时，我们期望结果
will be ranked for us by relevance to our search, but that is not how it works. So a place that's trying to sell something is trying to sell, like if it has more of one thing in its warehouse than another, it'll try to push that on to you. If it has something that's on sale, it might show you that first. If it has a product where the people who make it have a pay for play deal with the e-commerce site, it'll show you that stuff first. The result is that the thing you search for that you are trying to buy will be buried by results for stuff that the company wants you to buy. You can put in the specific name of
will be ranked for us by relevance to our search, but that is not how it works. So a place that's trying to sell something is trying to sell, like if it has more of one thing in its warehouse than another, it's trying to push that on to you. If it has something that's on sale, it might show you that first. If it has a product where the people who make it have a pay for play deal with the e-commerce site, it'll show you that stuff first. The result is that the thing you search for that you are trying to buy will be buried by results for stuff that the company wants you to buy. You can put in the specific name of|||会根据与我们搜索的相关性来为我们排序，但实际情况并非如此。因此，一个试图卖东西的地方，比如它仓库里某种东西比另一种东西多，它就会试图把这个推销给你。如果有什么东西正在促销，它可能会首先向你展示这个。如果某种产品的制造商与电商网站达成了一笔付费推广的交易，它就会先把这些东西展示给你。结果就是，你搜索并试图购买的东西，会被公司想让你买的东西的搜索结果给淹没。你可以在亚马逊的搜索栏里输入某个商品的具体名称，
something in the search bar in Amazon and it won't show up until you scroll to your three screens down. And that, I mean, I'm still shocked by that. I'm naive or I'm stupid or something. I'm stunned like, no, I put in the name of the book. I know what book I want. And you still got to scroll to find it because there are all kinds of other competitive commercial pressures.
something in the search bar in Amazon and it won't show up until you scroll to your three screens down. And that, I mean, I'm still shocked by that. I'm naive or I'm stupid or something. I'm stunned like, no, I put in the name of the book. I know what book I want. And you still got to scroll to find it because there are all kinds of other competitive commercial pressures.|||但直到你往下滚动三屏后它才会出现。对此，我的意思是，我至今仍感到震惊。我是太天真还是太傻了什么的。我惊呆了，心想：不对啊，我输入的是书名。我知道自己想要哪本书。但你仍然得拼命往下滚动才能找到它，因为这里充斥着各种各样的其他商业竞争压力。
The same thing happens with private search when we're trying to retrieve something like a flight confirmation number or a vacation photo from the cloud. On some level, we expect every search bar to work like Google's, even though it isn't Google. So personal information management turns out to still be kind of an unsolved problem more so than wide search. Adam says that the reason searching your own files isn't as streamlined as web search is because your personal email or photo database is private. Software engineers can't improve on algorithms as easily as Google can on the web because with their private data, there's less statistical commonalities to draw from.
The same thing happens with private search when we're trying to retrieve something like a flight confirmation number or a vacation photo from the cloud. On some level, we expect every search bar to work like Google's, even though itisn't Google. So personal information management turns out to still be kind of an unsolved problem more so than wide search. Adam says that the reason searching your own files isn't as streamlined as web search is because your personal email or photo database is private. Software engineers can't improve on algorithms as easily as Google can on the web because with their private data, there's less statistical commonalities to draw from.|||当我们尝试从云端检索诸如航班确认号或度假照片之类的内容时，私人搜索也会遇到同样的情况。在某种程度上，我们期望每个搜索栏都像 Google 的一样好用，尽管它根本不是 Google。因此，事实证明，个人信息管理依然是一个尚未解决的难题，其难度甚至超过了全网搜索。亚当表示，搜索你自己的文件之所以不像网页搜索那样顺畅，是因为你的个人电子邮件或照片数据库是私密的。软件工程师无法像 Google 优化网页算法那样轻易地改进算法，因为对于个人私密数据而言，可供提取的统计共性要少得多。
Great assault here. Google supposedly doesn't release information about this, so we don't know for sure about all that. What we do know is that not being able to find our stuff can have consequences. And that's a personal and also a cultural amnesia that I think becomes troubling. You lose moments from the past. You end up only existing in the moment like where you share the stuff and then it doesn't exist anymore because you can't go back and search it.
Great assault here. Google supposedly doesn't release information about this, so we don't know for sure about all that. What we do know is that not being able to find our stuff can have consequences. And that's a personal and also a cultural amnesia that I think becomes troubling. You lose moments from the past. You end up only existing in the moment like where you share the stuff and then it doesn't exist anymore because you can't go back and search it.|||这里有个重大攻击……（注：此处可能为口误或原文转录错误，指代“重大冲击或影响”）据称 Google 不会公开这方面的信息，所以我们对此无法确凿知晓。我们确实知道的是，找不到我们的东西可能会带来后果。我认为，这是一种个人乃至文化的失忆症，变得令人不安。你失去了过去的时刻。你最终只能活在当下，比如你分享了某些东西，然后它就不复存在了，因为你无法再回头去搜索它。
In the years since Google rose to prominence, it set the standard for what search could be, but lately that glow seems to be fading. And in fact, it turns out that almost as soon as it was born, Google almost without us noticing began to fail. I found it incredibly chilling to be talking to somebody who works on search at Google and have that person say, yeah, search really isn't a solved problem. And it hasn't been for a long time. In the early 2000s,
In the years since Google rose to prominence, it set the standard for what search could be, but lately that glow seems to be fading. And in fact, it turns out that almost as soon as it was born, Google almost without us noticing began to fail. I found it incredibly chilling to be talking to somebody who works on search at Google and have that person say, yeah, search really isn't a solved problem. And it hasn't been for a long time. In the early 2000s,|||自从 Google 声名鹊起以来的这些年里，它为“搜索应该是什么样”树立了标准，但最近这种光环似乎正在消褪。事实上，事实证明，几乎在它诞生后不久，在几乎没有引起我们注意的情况下，Google 就开始走下坡路了。我发现与一个在 Google 从事搜索工作的人交谈时，听到对方说“是的，搜索其实并不是一个已经解决的问题，而且很久以来都不是”是一件极其让人不寒而栗的事。在2000年代初，
Google started getting bogged down by monetization and people trying to gain the system. One way this played out was with SEO or search engine optimization. SEO is basically the process of getting a web page ranked higher in web search results. In the early years of SEO, webmasters would often stuff their web pages with keywords to get them to rank higher, regardless of actual relevance, and the strategies keep evolving. I was just reading some folks today talking about this on social media about how like everything you look for on Google has these like 2,000 word introductions of meaningless gibberish, like before you get to the recipe,
Google started getting bogged down by monetization and people trying to gain the system. One way this played out was with SEO or search engine optimization. SEO is basically the process of getting a web page ranked higher in web search results. In the early years of SEO, webmasters would often stuff their web pages with keywords to get them to rank higher, regardless of actual relevance, and the strategies keep evolving. I was just reading some folks today talking about this on social media about how like everything you look for on Google has these like 2,000 word introductions of meaningless gibberish, like before you get to the recipe,|||Google 开始陷入商业化的泥潭，人们也开始试图钻系统的空子。其中一种表现形式就是 SEO（搜索引擎优化）。SEO 基本上就是让网页在网页搜索结果中获得更高排名的过程。在 SEO 的早期，站长们经常在网页中塞满关键词，以求获得更高的排名，而不管其实际相关性如何，并且这些策略一直在不断演变。我今天刚看到社交媒体上有人在讨论这个：你在 Google 上找的任何东西，在正文前都有大约2000字毫无意义的废话介绍，比如在给出食谱之前，
or before you get to the instructions for changing the memory card or whatever. And that's because one of the things that Google came to prioritize, it seems, they're not that open about these things, is how long somebody spends on the page At all that up and this is what you get when you type in a web search query It can feel like you're playing hide and seek but for information to find the thing you search for First you'll need to scroll past rows of stuff labeled ads or maps and horizontal boxes of questions
or before you get to the instructions for changing the memory card or whatever. And that's because one of the things that Google came to prioritize, it seems, they're not that open about these things, is how long somebody spends on the page At all that up and this is what you get when you type in a web search query It can feel like you're playing hide and seek but for information to find the thing you search for First you'll need to scroll past rows of stuff labeled ads or maps and horizontal boxes of questions|||或者在给出更换存储卡之类的说明之前。这是因为 Google 开始优先考虑的事情之一（尽管他们对此并不是很公开）似乎是用户在页面上停留的时间。把所有这些加起来，这就是你在输入网页搜索查询时所遇到的情况：感觉就像在玩捉迷藏，只不过寻找的是信息。为了找到你搜索的东西，你首先需要滚动鼠标，掠过一排排标有“广告”或“地图”的内容，以及包含各种问题的横向框。
You didn't ask. Another reason search engines like Google so often miss their mark is because, unlike say, a librarians approach, which might be more like, here are 10 bucks you could read to try to figure out on your own. Google tries to give you the most popular quote-unquote best search results. In other words, a direct answer. It can sort of understand what's on a web page, find the information that it thinks you are looking for based on its statistical analysis of all of the billions and billions of searches
You didn't ask. Another reason search engines like Google so often miss their mark is because, unlike say, a librarians approach, which might be more like, here are 10 bucks you could read to try to figure out on your own. Google tries to give you the most popular quote-unquote best search results. In other words, a direct answer. It can sort of understand what's on a web page, find the information that it thinks you are looking for based on its statistical analysis of all of the billions and billions of searches|||你根本没问过的问题。像 Google 这样的搜索引擎之所以经常偏离目标，另一个原因在于：与图书馆员的方法（可能更像是“这里有10本书，你可以拿去读，自己试着找答案”）不同，Google 试图为你提供最受欢迎的、所谓的“最佳”搜索结果。换句话说，就是一个直接的答案。它能够大致理解网页上的内容，根据对数以亿计的搜索的统计分析，找到它认为你在寻找的信息，
that it sees all the time, and feed you an answer. And we now have come to think, oh, well, that must be the answer, then. But when a search engine prioritizes the visibility of one seemingly popular answer over another, sometimes it can lead to misleading or even harmful outcomes, like in 2021, when the result of a single Google search sparked an uproar in India. An angry flashpoint has emerged in Karnataka after search engine Google showed Kanada language in bad light calling it the ugliest language in the country.
that it sees all the time, and feed you an answer. And we now have come to think, oh, well, that must be the answer, then. But when a search engine prioritizes the visibility of one seemingly popular answer over another, sometimes it can lead to misleading or even harmful outcomes, like in 2021, when the result of a single Google search sparked an uproar in India. An angry flashpoint has emerged in Karnataka after search engine Google showed Kanada language in bad light calling it the ugliest language in the country.|||并直接塞给你一个答案。而我们现在已经习惯于认为：哦，好吧，那这肯定就是答案了。但当搜索引擎优先展示某个看似受欢迎的答案而忽略其他时，有时会导致误导甚至有害的结果，比如在2021年，单单一次 Google 搜索的结果就在印度引发了一场轩然大波。在搜索引擎 Google 将卡纳达语描绘成不好的形象、称其为该国“最丑陋的语言”之后，卡纳达邦爆发了愤怒的抗议焦点。
Huge outcry was triggered after this news. Someone had typed the words ugliest language in India into Google and the search engine embarrassingly answered. Google named an actual language in India and insulted 43 million people in the process. Doutrage prompted Google to issue a detailed statement apologizing for the gap and said they would improve their algorithm. But the Karnataka government has made it clear and apology is not enough.
Huge outcry was triggered after this news. Someone had typed the words ugliest language in India into Google and the search engine embarrassingly answered. Google named an actual language in India and insulted 43 million people in the process. Doutrage prompted Google to issue a detailed statement apologizing for the gap and said they would improve their algorithm. But the Karnataka government has made it clear and apology is not enough.|||这则新闻引发了巨大的抗议浪潮。有人在 Google 中输入了“印度最丑陋的语言”这几个字，而搜索引擎竟然给出了一个令人尴尬的回答。Google 在回应中点名了印度的一种真实语言，并在这一过程中侮辱了4300万人口。这起愤怒事件促使 Google 发表了一份详细声明，为这一疏漏道歉，并表示将改进其算法。但卡纳达邦政府已经明确表示，道歉是远远不够的。
They could send a legal notice. So in line of all this, search engines are evolving again. To fix the issue of private search, not working like the Google search bar, some search companies are supposedly considering creating search engines that could dig through both your personal information and go out on the web. You'll pay us a little bit of money, and then it'll be private. And we'll search your personal information as well as the web, and we'll do it really well, you know, so you'll be able to find your flight confirmation number
They could send a legal notice. So in line of all this, search engines are evolving again. To fix the issue of private search, not working like the Google search bar, some search companies are supposedly considering creating search engines that could dig through both your personal information and go out on the web. You'll pay us a little bit of money, and then it'll be private. And we'll search your personal information as well as the web, and we'll do it really well, you know, so you'll be able to find your flight confirmation number|||他们可能会发出法律通知。鉴于这一切，搜索引擎正在再次演变。为了解决私人搜索不像 Google 搜索栏那样好用的问题，据说一些搜索公司正在考虑开发能够同时深入挖掘你的个人信息和互联网的搜索引擎。你付给我们一点钱，然后它就是私密的。我们既会搜索你的个人信息，也会搜索网络，而且我们会做得非常出色，你知道的，这样你就能找到你的航班确认号、
and your freaking flyer number, and the name of that person who you worked with that one time, and all that other stuff that we searched for in our own computer, that one document. And to fix the issue of constrained single answer results, Google announced last year an AI technology that would attempt to understand not just what the searcher is typing, but what the searcher is thinking.
and your freaking flyer number, and the name of that person who you worked with that one time, and all that other stuff that we searched for in our own computer, that one document. And to fix the issue of constrained single answer results, Google announced last year an AI technology that would attempt to understand not just what the searcher is typing, but what the searcher is thinking.|||你那该死的常旅客卡号、你曾合作过一次的那个人的名字，以及我们在自己的电脑里搜索过的所有其他东西——那份文档。为了解决受限的单一答案结果的问题，Google 去年宣布推出一项人工智能技术，该技术将试图不仅理解搜索者在输入什么，还要理解搜索者在想什么。
Meaning, the search would no longer be driven by topic or keyword, but by what the AI thinks the searcher meant by those words. You can have a kind of iterative back and forth, because you'll have a search engine that actually understands language instead of just looks for keywords. There's a promise in this, and there's also a risk that as search companies start to behave more like humans with their own ideas, they might continue to algorithmically nudge us away from our intended searches and into unexpected directions, which feels creepy and consequential if you think about all the life decisions that you make in a given year based on information you process after googling.
Meaning, the search would no longer be driven by topic or keyword, but by what the AI thinks the searcher meant by those words. You can have a kind of iterative back and forth, because you'll have a search engine that actually understands language instead of just looks for keywords. There's a promise in this, and there's also a risk that as search companies start to behave more like humans with their own ideas, they might continue to algorithmically nudge us away from our intended searches and into unexpected directions, which feels creepy and consequential if you think about all the life decisions that you make in a given year based on information you process after googling.|||这意味着，搜索将不再由主题或关键词驱动，而是由 AI 认为搜索者通过这些词所表达的意图来驱动。你可以进行某种迭代式的来回互动，因为你将拥有一个真正理解语言而不仅仅是寻找关键词的搜索引擎。这其中蕴含着美好的前景，但也存在风险：随着搜索公司开始变得更像拥有自己想法的人类，它们可能会继续通过算法将我们从预期的搜索意图中推开，引导我们走向意想不到的方向。如果你仔细想想在某一年里，你基于通过 Google 搜索处理的信息所做出的所有重大生活决策，就会觉得这既诡异又影响深远。
But Google's vision of the future points to something already starting to happen in the world of search, this time on the part of the searcher. One move that a lot of people now use is they will use Google with the keywords that they have to search for, but tell it to only search Reddit. with the keywords that they have to search for, but tell it to only search Reddit. Increasingly, people are turning to Reddit to search for information, but they're using Google to do it, because Reddit's own search function is supposedly not very good.
But Google's vision of the future points to something already starting to happen in the world of search, this time on the part of the searcher. One move that a lot of people now use is they will use Google with the keywords that they have to search for, but tell it to only search Reddit. with the keywords that they have to search for, but tell it to only search Reddit. Increasingly, people are turning to Reddit to search for information, but they're using Google to do it, because Reddit's own search function is supposedly not very good.|||但 Google 对未来的展望指向了搜索世界中已经开始发生的事情，这一次是由搜索者主动发起的。现在许多人都在使用的一个招数是：他们会结合要搜索的关键词使用 Google，但会限定只在 Reddit 上搜索。随着越来越多的人转向 Reddit 寻找信息，但他们却借助 Google 来完成这一过程，因为据说 Reddit 自身的搜索功能不是很好用。
So you can use Google to find the subject, and then you have human beings actually answering your question. On Reddit, someone looking for information on keeping their garden vegetables alive can ease drop on a conversation between niche experts in humid or desert climates for a particular plant. Or they can engage in a real human conversation about say how much water does a thing actually need using Google to search Reddit for human conversations. It's a little janky, but it may be the best
So you can use Google to find the subject, and then you have human beings actually answering your question. On Reddit, someone looking for information on keeping their garden vegetables alive can ease drop on a conversation between niche experts in humid or desert climates for a particular plant. Or they can engage in a real human conversation about say how much water does a thing actually need using Google to search Reddit for human conversations. It's a little janky, but it may be the best|||所以你可以用 Google 来找到主题，然后就会有活生生的人来真正回答你的问题。在 Reddit 上，一个寻找如何让花园蔬菜存活方法的人，可以旁听潮湿或沙漠气候下针对特定植物的小众专家之间的对话。或者他们可以进行真正的人类对话，比如通过 Google 搜索 Reddit 上的真人对话来了解某个东西究竟需要多少水分。这方法虽然有点粗糙，但它可能是目前我们拥有的
solution for a search that we have right now. In a way, it comes close to replicating the experience of talking to a good old-fashioned librarian. The thing that the conversation with the reference librarian that was the classic model of search would give you is if you didn't really know what you were looking for, the reference librarian would help you figure out what you were looking for.
solution for a search that we have right now. In a way, it comes close to replicating the experience of talking to a good old-fashioned librarian. The thing that the conversation with the reference librarian that was the classic model of search would give you is if you didn't really know what you were looking for, the reference librarian would help you figure out what you were looking for.|||最好的搜索解决方案了。从某种程度上说，它几乎复制了与老派优秀的图书管理员交谈的体验。作为经典搜索模式的与参考咨询馆员的对话能带给你的是：如果你真的不知道自己在找什么，参考咨询馆员会帮你弄清楚你到底在找什么。
It turns out you were looking for something different. It turns out there's a whole related thing. There's a whole other room of the library that has more that you might want. Between Google's new AI and the wild world of Reddit, the future of search is beginning to look a lot like the past. Ultimately, the questions pertaining to search aren't getting easy answers anytime soon. Questions like, could there be a better way to order the world's information? How do we organize the stuff that we know so that the next person can know it too?
It turns out you were looking for something different. It turns out there's a whole related thing. There's a whole other room of the library that has more that you might want. Between Google's new AI and the wild world of Reddit, the future of search is beginning to look a lot like the past. Ultimately, the questions pertaining to search aren't getting easy answers anytime soon. Questions like, could there be a better way to order the world's information? How do we organize the stuff that we know so that the next person can know it too?|||结果你会发现，你其实在找别的东西。你会发现还有一整套与之相关的东西。图书馆里还有另一个房间，里面有更多你可能想要的内容。在 Google 的新 AI 和光怪陆离的 Reddit 世界之间，搜索的未来开始变得越来越像过去。归根结底，与搜索相关的问题在短期内不会有简单的答案。比如这些问题：有没有更好的方式来整理全世界的信息？我们该如何组织我们所知道的事物，以便下一个人也能了解它们？
And what time am I flying out of JFK anyway? These are some big questions, the answers to which we may never know. Coming up after the break, I talk with our digital director, Kurt Coleset, about his personal favorite approach to searching. So when we were making this episode, Losh and I were light in part on another 99PI colleague to help us better understand search, both its history and work around to use search more effectively. And so we called on Kurt Colestead Digital Director. There's a reason why he's called Digital Director. And so he's joined me to go through
And what time am I flying out of JFK anyway? These are some big questions, the answers to which we may never know. Coming up after the break, I talk with our digital director, Kurt Coleset, about his personal favorite approach to searching. So when we were making this episode, Losh and I were light in part on another 99PI colleague to help us better understand search, both its history and work around to use search more effectively. And so we called on Kurt Colestead Digital Director. There's a reason why he's called Digital Director. And so he's joined me to go through|||我到底是什么时候从肯尼迪机场起飞来着？这些都是重大问题，其答案我们可能永远不得而知。广告之后，我将与我们的数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特（Kurt Coleset）聊聊他个人最喜欢的搜索方法。因此，在制作这期节目时，我和洛什部分依赖了另一位 99PI 的同事来帮助我们更好地理解搜索，包括它的历史以及更有效地使用搜索的变通方法。于是我们请来了数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特。他被称为数字总监是有原因的。因此他加入了我的节目，和我们一起深入探讨
both of those in a little bit more in depth. I've been steeped in this world of search for a very long time now. And like everybody else, I have to search for stuff, but I also ran a number of web publications which relied in part on visitors from search engines for ad revenue.
both of those in a little bit more in depth. I've been steeped in this world of search for a very long time now. And like everybody else, I have to search for stuff, but I also ran a number of web publications which relied in part on visitors from search engines for ad revenue.|||这两方面的内容。我浸润在搜索这个世界已经很长时间了。和大家一样，我必须搜索各种东西，但我也运营过许多网络出版物，这些出版物在一定程度上依赖来自搜索引擎的访客来获取广告收入。
So yeah, it's fair to say I have spent some time studying SEO. Yeah, and that is search engine optimization, which I know kind of peripherally from having stuff on the web for a while. Yeah, so what is that? Well, as a person who ran websites using SEO, what is that all about? So a lot of it is white hat, right?
So yeah, it's fair to say I have spent some time studying SEO. Yeah, and that is search engine optimization, which I know kind of peripherally from having stuff on the web for a while. Yeah, so what is that? Well, as a person who ran websites using SEO, what is that all about? So a lot of it is white hat, right?|||所以，是的，平心而论，我花了不少时间研究 SEO。对，也就是搜索引擎优化，由于在网上发布过一些内容，我对它略有所闻。对，那究竟是什么呢？好吧，作为一个运营过使用 SEO 网站的人，这到底是怎么一回事？所以其中很大一部分是白帽手法，对吧？
It's like above board stuff like, hey, I've got a local architecture firm and when people search for art and architecture firm in this area, I should show up in the search results. But a lot of it is ethically much murkier, and it's been that way basically from the beginning. Okay, so what are some examples of the beginning of people using SEO in a bad way? Right, so I have one of me using it in a bad way,
It's like above board stuff like, hey, I'm local architecture firm and when people search for art and architecture firm in this area, I should show up in the search results. But a lot of it is ethically much murkier, and it's been that way basically from the beginning. Okay, so what are some examples of the beginning of people using SEO in a bad way? Right, so I have one of me using it in a bad way,|||这就像是光明磊落的事情，比如：嘿，我是一家本地建筑事务所，当人们搜索该地区的艺术与建筑事务所时，我应该出现在搜索结果中。但其中很大一部分在道德上要阴暗得多，而且基本上从一开始就是这样的。好的，那么人们以不良方式使用 SEO 的初期例子有哪些呢？好吧，我就有一个自己曾以不良方式使用它的例子，
which is that, yeah, I'm not a teenager. I call it coming from inside the house. That was coming from, um, you know, call it's coming from inside the house. Yeah, it's coming from, yes, yes. So in the, in the 90s, I built a fan page for a band that I will never tell you the name of, um, out of sheer embarrassment. And one of the things I did was add in any word I thought somebody might search in relation to a band like other similar bands and stuff like that.
which is that, yeah, I'm not a teenager. I call it coming from inside the house. That was coming from, um, you know, call it's coming from inside the house. Yeah, it's coming from, yes, yes. So in the, in the 1990s, I built a fan page for a band that I will never tell you the name of, um, out of sheer embarrassment. And one of the things I did was add in any word I thought somebody might search in relation to a band like other similar bands and stuff like that.|||那就是——好吧，我可不是青少年了。我称之为“祸起萧墙”（来自内部）。那是来自……嗯，你知道的，就叫它“祸起萧墙”吧。对，就是来自……好，好。所以在20世纪90年代，我为一个乐队建立了一个粉丝网页（出于纯粹的尴尬，我绝不会告诉你这个乐队的名字）。我做的事情之一就是添加了我认为别人可能会搜索到的与该乐队相关的任何词汇，比如其他类似的乐队之类的东西。
Just tons and tons of these words at the bottom of the page in small format. And sort of half hidden, you know, with the color that kind of matched the page. I mean, I was, you know, basically, yeah. Well, turns out this is a well-known tactic called keyword stuffing. And it used to kind of work.
Just tons and tons of these words at the bottom of the page in small format. And sort of half hidden, you know, with the color that kind of matched the page. I mean, I was, you know, basically, yeah. Well, turns out this is a well-known tactic called keyword stuffing. And it used to kind of work.|||页面底部堆满了密密麻麻的小字号这些词汇。而且有点半隐藏着，你知道的，颜色和页面背景差不多。我的意思是，我当时……基本上就是这样。好吧，事实证明这是一种著名的策略，叫做“关键词堆砌”。而且它过去确实有点用。
Like Google used to be a little bit simpler and would just kind of read what's on the page and try to deliver results. But of course, these days, the AI is much more sophisticated. And if you actually try to do that today, Google will not only catch you, but they will like potentially delist your site for doing something like that.
Like Google used to be a little bit simpler and would just kind of read what's on the page and try to deliver results. But of course, these days, the AI is much more sophisticated. And if you actually try to do that today, Google will not only catch you, but they will like potentially delist your site for doing something like that.|||就像 Google 过去要简单一些，只会大致阅读页面上的内容并试图给出结果。但当然，如今的 AI 要复杂得多。如果你今天真的试图这么做，Google 不仅会抓包，还可能会因为你做了这种事而将你的网站直接除名。
Hmm, okay. So if the algorithm is getting smarter and catching these kinds of things, why isn't search just getting better and better? Yeah. So the search engine optimization industry is huge and they're highly motivated. So every time Google comes up with something, they come up with something else. And it makes sense if you think about it. Like they throw so much money at this because if they can get their business to come up first in a search organically, as it's called,
Hmm, okay. So if the algorithm is getting smarter and catching these kinds of things, why isn't search just getting better and better? Yeah. So the search engine optimization industry is huge and they're highly motivated. So every time Google comes up with something, they come up with something else. And it makes sense if you think about it. Like they throw so much money at this because if they can get their business to come up first in a search organically, as it's called,|||嗯，好的。那么，如果算法变得越来越聪明并且能抓住这类事情，为什么搜索没有变得越来越好呢？对。所以搜索引擎优化行业体量巨大，而且他们有着极高的动力。因此，每当 Google 推出一项新举措时，他们就会想出另一套对策。如果你仔细想想，这其实很合逻辑。比如他们在这上面砸了巨资，因为如果他们能让自己的企业在搜索中自然排在第一位（也就是所谓的自然排名），
like without having to pay for ads or anything, it can mean the difference between success and failure, right? So everyone is forced to get more clever about their strategies and then Google for its part has become a lot less transparent over time about what they factor into their search results. And for good reason, right, to deter these unethical players who learn the rules and then learn how to cheat from them. Yeah. So it's kind of this arms race, but also like things get more secret as part of the arms race as well.
like without having to pay for ads or anything, it can mean the difference between success and failure, right? So everyone is forced to get more clever about their strategies and then Google for its part has become a lot less transparent over time about what they factor into their search results. And for good reason, right, to deter these unethical players who learn the rules and then learn how to cheat from them. Yeah. So it's kind of this arms race, but also like things get more secret as part of the arms race as well.|||也就是无需为广告或其他东西付费，这就意味着成功与失败的云泥之别，对吧？所以每个人都被迫在策略上变得更聪明，而 Google 方面，随着时间的推移，对于其搜索结果中纳入考量的因素变得越来越不透明。这也是有充分理由的，对吧？为了阻止那些先学会规则然后又学会如何作弊的不道德玩家。是的。所以这有点像是一场军备竞赛，但同时，作为军备竞赛的一部分，事情也变得越来越神秘。
And so, you know, given the current state quantitative things, you know, what is your advice for people trying to search and find stuff? Well, it depends upon the kind of thing as you'd imagine, but I want to walk you and our listeners through my personal favorite strategy, which honestly, I use to search for everything from beard trimmer reviews to tips for taking care of suckiness. Okay. And so, let's start with the first example. And that's called a transactional search, right?
And so, you know, given the current state quantitative things, you know, what is your advice for people trying to search and find stuff? Well, it depends upon the kind of thing as you'd imagine, but I want to walk you and our listeners through my personal favorite strategy, which honestly, I use to search for everything from beard trimmer reviews to tips for taking care of suckiness. Okay. And so, let's start with the first example. And that's called a transactional search, right?|||所以，你知道的，鉴于目前的定量情况（注：原文如此），对于想要搜索和寻找东西的人，你有什么建议吗？嗯，如你所料，这取决于具体是什么东西，但我希望能带你和我们的听众了解我个人最喜欢的策略。说实话，我用这个策略搜索各种东西——从胡须修剪器评测到照顾吸毒上瘾者的建议（注：suckiness疑为口误或转录错漏）。好的。那么，让我们从第一个例子开始。这被称为事务性搜索（Transactional search），对吧？
Like, I'm looking to buy a beard trimmer. Okay. I mean, I know that you mentioned it. I seem to need a new beard trimmer all the time, so I'm apparently not buying the right beard trimmer. So, so. Same here. They always seem to break.
Like, I'm looking to buy a beard trimmer. Okay. I mean, I know that you mentioned it. I seem to need a new beard trimmer all the time, so I'm apparently not buying the right beard trimmer. So, so. Same here. They always seem to break.|||比如，我正打算买一个胡须修剪器。好的。我的意思是，我知道你提过这事。我好像总是需要一个新的胡须修剪器，所以我显然一直没买到对的修剪器。所以，所以。我也是。它们好像总是坏。
Yeah, they do. Allmer. So, so. Seeming they always seem to break. Yeah, they do. All right. Yeah. OK. So I could start on Amazon and type in beard trimmer and then sort those results by average customer reviews because that way at least hopefully you get the best ones first.
Yeah, they do. Allmer. So, so. Seeming they always seem to break. Yeah, they do. All right. Yeah. OK. So I could start on Amazon and type in beard trimmer and then sort those results by average customer reviews because that way at least hopefully you get the best ones first.|||确实如此。所有的修剪器……所以，所以。似乎它们总是坏。是的，确实如此。好吧。是的。好的。所以我可以从亚马逊开始，输入“胡须修剪器”，然后根据平均客户评价对这些结果进行排序，因为这样至少有望让你先把最好的产品筛选出来。
Yeah. And that can work. Or I can search in Google and click the shopping tab. And, you know, I'll get some results there. But here's what I actually do. In Google, type in something like Best Beard Trimmer, then site colon reddit.com. And that way, you'll only get results from Reddit's website. And for those who don't know, Reddit is this huge website with tons of subforms called
Yeah. And that can work. Or I can search in Google and click the shopping tab. And, you know, I'll get some results there. But here's what I actually do. In Google, type in something like Best Beard Trimmer, then site colon reddit.com. And that way, you'll only get results from Reddit's website. And for those who don't know, Reddit is this huge website with tons of subforms called|||对。这确实行得通。或者我可以在 Google 中搜索并点击购物标签。然后，你知道的，我会在那里得到一些结果。但我的实际做法是这样的。在 Google 中输入诸如“最佳胡须修剪器”之类的词，然后加上 site:reddit.com。这样一来，你只会得到来自 Reddit 网站的结果。对于那些不知道的人来说，Reddit 是一个拥有大量子论坛（称为 subreddit）的庞大网站，
subreddits. And there are some of these that are really big like news and some are really niche subjects like Ben's hair care. And I'm pretty much, you know, I follow with the logic of this is, but I guess my question is, why would you trust Reddit, over say like reviews on Amazon or third party website? It seems like it's still user reviews in a way. Yeah, I mean, that's a great question. Because you wouldn't think, it just seems kind of random, right?
subreddits. And there are some of these that are really big like news and some are really niche subjects like Ben's hair care. And I'm pretty much, you know, I follow with the logic of this is, but I guess my question is, why would you trust Reddit, over say like reviews on Amazon or third party website? It seems like it's still user reviews in a way. Yeah, I mean, that's a great question. Because you wouldn't think, it just seems kind of random, right?|||其中一些规模非常宏大，比如新闻类，而另一些则非常小众，比如本的护发经（Ben's hair care）。我基本上……你知道的，我能理解这背后的逻辑，但我想问的问题是：为什么你会信任 Reddit，而不是像亚马逊上的评论或第三方网站上的评测呢？从某种程度上讲，这似乎仍然是用户评论啊。是的，我的意思是，这是个极好的问题。因为你可能不会想到，这看起来似乎有点随机，对吧？
But the reality is that review websites, particularly ones that have gained their way to the top of Google, are a crapshoot. You might find legitimately good and helpful reviews, or you might find somebody who's writing about a product specifically because they'll get a commission if you click a link on their site and buy that product. And then on Amazon, reviews have become sketchier
But the reality is that review websites, particularly ones that have gained their way to the top of Google, are a crapshoot. You might find legitimately good and helpful reviews, or you might find somebody who's writing about a product specifically because they'll get a commission if you click a link on their site and buy that product. And then on Amazon, reviews have become sketchier|||但现实情况是，评测网站，尤其是那些通过优化手段爬到 Google 搜索结果顶部的网站，简直就像是在碰运气。你可能会找到真正好且有帮助的评测，也可能会遇到这样的人：他们撰写关于某款产品的文章，纯粹是因为如果你点击他们网站上的链接并购买了该产品，他们就能拿到佣金。而在亚马逊上，评论也变得越来越可疑、
and sketchier over the years for various reasons that some of which we talked about in this episode. Yeah, and you can feel it. You know what I'm saying? When you look at Amazon. Yeah, you really can, right? But on Reddit, there are these subreddits for virtually anything and gaming every related Community to a certain product or or something
and sketchier over the years for various reasons that some of which we talked about in this episode. Yeah, and you can feel it. You know what I'm saying? When you look at Amazon. Yeah, you really can, right? But on Reddit, there are these subreddits for virtually anything and gaming every related Community to a certain product or or something|||越来越不靠谱了，原因有很多，我们在本期节目中已经讨论过其中一部分。是的，你完全能感觉得到。你知道我在说什么吧？当你浏览亚马逊时。是的，你真的能感觉得到，对吧？但在 Reddit 上，几乎针对任何事物都有对应的 subreddit，并且有针对特定产品或诸如此类的每一个相关社群，
It would actually be pretty hard to you. Maybe someday AI is will figure it out But for now, it's kind of out of reach for most SEOs And with that beard trimmer search, for instance, I put this in and I landed on conversations in a subreddit called OneBag, which is a community I didn't even know about, that's all about minimalist travel. So that's cool, right? That's relevant. Like those guys probably know what they're doing.
It would actually be pretty hard to you. Maybe someday AI is will figure it out But for now, it's kind of out of reach for most SEOs And with that beard trimmer search, for instance, I put this in and I landed on conversations in a subreddit called OneBag, which is a community I didn't even know about, that's all about minimalist travel. So that's cool, right? That's relevant. Like those guys probably know what they're doing.|||对你来说其实很难……也许有一天人工智能会攻克这一点，但就目前而言，它对大多数 SEO 从业者来说还是有些遥不可及。以搜索胡须修剪器为例，我输入了这个词，然后进入了一个名为 OneBag 的 subreddit 上的讨论串——这是一个我之前甚至不知道的社群，专门讨论极简主义旅行。所以这很酷，对吧？这很相关。那些家伙很可能知道自己在做什么。
And then I also found a search result in Buy It for life, which as you can imagine, is people discussing high quality things that hopefully will last the rest of their lives, right? Not cheap beer trimmers like ours to keep breaking. And the key part to this is there's no financial incentive for these people, right? Like they're not linking you out to products with commissions. They're just communities discussing these things openly, and they might not always be right, but there is this voting system. And so good things tend to rise to the top there.
然后我还发现了一个在Buy It For Life板块的搜索结果，你也可以想象，这是大家在讨论高质量的东西，希望它们能用一辈子，对吧？而不是像我们那种总是坏掉的便宜胡须修剪器。这其中的关键在于，这些人没有任何经济利益驱动，对吧？比如他们不会带佣金链接指向产品。这只是社区在公开讨论这些东西，虽然他们可能并不总是对的，但这里有投票系统。所以好的东西往往会在那里脱颖而出。
So if I were to do a search like this, would I want to look for the highest voted result? Is that how it works? Yeah, I mean, that is a good place to start at least. And beyond that, too, usually there will be responses to that top voted thing. And beyond that too, usually there will be responses to that top-voted thing. And people will discuss things back and forth pointing out downsides or suggesting alternatives in these comet threads.
所以如果我要做这样的搜索，我会想找得票最高的搜索结果吗？是这样运作的吗？对，我的意思是，这至少是一个很好的起点。除此之外，通常也会有人回复那个得票最高的东西。除此之外，通常也会有人回复那个得票最高的东西。人们会在这些评论串里来回讨论，指出缺点或提出替代方案。
Wow. I mean, I think I've noticed this happening more and more that Reddit has been part of my searching for information. And it's really kind of makes a ton of sense. And so that's very cool. But I never thought of it as something so practical as looking makes a ton of sense. And so that's very cool. But I never thought of it as something so practical as looking for a beer trimmer. It was always like a piece of information or a few people discussing, yeah. Totally, totally.
哇。我的意思是，我觉得我越来越注意到这种情况发生了，Reddit已经成为我信息搜索的一部分。这确实挺有道理的。所以这非常酷。但我从来没有想过它会像找一个胡须修剪器那么实用。它总是像一条信息或者几个人在讨论，是的。完全是这样，完全是这样。
And that's the sort of other domain of search, right? Is this category that's called informational search. And Reddit is really good for that too. So again, sort of starting from the beginning here. It's like you could go to YouTube and look for a tutorial about how to take care of your succulents. And often you'll get a pretty good results. But if you're just watching one video, you're getting one person's opinion and review websites, they're also usually monetized. So there could be a conflicting reason that they're making all these, making all these videos, right?
这也是搜索的另一种领域，对吧？就是被称为信息搜索的类别。Reddit在这方面也非常擅长。所以同样地，从头开始说起。就像你可以去YouTube寻找关于如何照顾多肉植物的教程。通常你会得到相当不错的结果。但如果你只看一个视频，你得到的就是一个人的意见，而且评论网站通常也是有商业化运作的。所以他们制作所有这些视频可能背后有冲突的原因，对吧？
They might not really be experts. And, you know, that obviously can work against your need to find impartial and useful advice. Right. So I assume this could take us back to Reddit where we could actually like some evaluation of even these videos. Yeah, exactly. And it's basically the same process as before, right? You search for a few keywords, you limit your search by putting site colon reddit.com. And I would argue that as good as reddit can be for product reviews, it's even better for expert advice because there are so many these tiny,
他们可能并不是真正的专家。而且，你知道，这显然会违背你寻找公正和有用建议的需求。对吧。所以我假设这可以把我们带回Reddit，在那里我们甚至可以对这些视频进行一些评估。对，完全正确。这基本上和以前的过程一样，对吧？你搜索几个关键词，通过加上site colon reddit.com来限制你的搜索。而且我认为，尽管Reddit对于产品评论很好，但对于专家建议来说它甚至更好，因为有那么多微小的、
niche subreddits about everything. So take succulents, for instance, there's a huge gardening subreddit, a smaller indoor gardening one, and an even smaller one that's just for succulents, and for some types of succulents, they even have their own whole community, which to me is crazy, but kind of beautiful too. Yeah, so this all makes sense to me, because you're really relying on human knowledge and voting and all the types of things that we've counted on since Web 2.0 came about.
关于各行各业的小众子板块。以多肉植物为例，有一个巨大的园艺板块，一个较小的室内园艺板块，还有一个更小的专门针对多肉植物的板块，对于某些种类的多肉植物，它们甚至有自己完整的社区，这对我来说很疯狂，但也挺美好的。是的，这一切对我都说得通，因为你真的在依赖人类的知识、投票以及自Web 2.0诞生以来我们一直依赖的各种类型的东西。
But my question is, you know, you can type a search into search bar on Reddit. So where are you using Google to search Reddit? That's a great question, too. I mean, I've tried that, believe me, I've tried that a lot of times, but Reddit's built in search is, in my opinion, a mess.
但我的问题是，你知道，你可以在Reddit的搜索栏里输入搜索。那么你为什么要用Google来搜索Reddit呢？这也是一个好问题。我的意思是，我试过，相信我，我试过很多次了，但在我看来，Reddit内置的搜索功能一团糟。
And it does offer various ways to search. So it kind of looks sophisticated, like you can search within a single subreddit, and you can sort results by, you know, the age of the post or the vote count on it. But ultimately, searchability has never really been the company's focus, and it shows when you actually try to search the site. So by using Google, you're combining this really powerful search engine with this really remarkable wealth of personal knowledge. You're cutting out all the bad results of random review websites, and you're just going
而且它确实提供了各种搜索方式。所以它看起来有点高级，比如你可以在单个子板块内搜索，你可以按帖子的发布时间或投票数对结果进行排序。但归根结底，搜索能力从来都不是公司的重点，当你真正尝试在网站上搜索时，这一点就显现出来了。因此，通过使用Google，你将这个非常强大的搜索引擎与这笔引人注目的个人知识财富结合起来。你摒弃了那些随机评论网站的所有不良结果，直接去往
straight to the site that often has good information. And of course, it won't work for everything, but it's a starting point for so many of my searches these days. And I should point out that the sort of third major category of search is something that Google actually does do very well. And that's called a navigational search. Basically, if you know what you're looking for, you're looking for a particular website or a person, plugging that into Google is often a great way to find them, right? Yeah. I mean, this is what we all do. But for these informational and transactional queries, I do suggest starting with Google plus Reddit and then just going from there. Wow. This is great. This is like real news you can use stuff right here.
往往有良好信息的网站。当然，它不可能适用于所有事情，但它是我如今很多搜索的起点。我应该指出，第三大主要搜索类别是Google确实做得很好的东西。这被称为导航搜索。基本上，如果你知道你在找什么，你在找一个特定的网站或一个人，把这个输入Google通常是找到他们的好方法，对吧？是的。我的意思是，这就是我们所有人都在做的。但对于这些信息和交易查询，我确实建议从Google加Reddit开始，然后再从那里继续。哇。这太棒了。这就像是真正你能用得上的实用新闻。
Yeah. So I'm going to give the hybrid search a shot and I'll let you know how it goes. Excellent. Yeah, I mean, yeah, rarely are we so practical at our, in our episodes. But yeah, hopefully people find this useful. I should mention one other thing before we go. And that's that for some people, Reddit will set off a bit of a red flag because the site is a whole, is a very mixed bag. It's sort of like its own version of the worldwide web with warts and all. So for people who have a negative
是的。所以我要尝试一下这种混合搜索，然后我会告诉你进展如何。太棒了。是的，我的意思是，我们的节目很少这么务实。但希望大家觉得这有用。在我离开之前，我应该提到另一件事。那就是对于有些人来说，Reddit会引发一些红旗警告，因为整个网站是一个大杂烩。它有点像是万维网自己的版本，包含了所有的缺点。所以对于那些带着负面印象去的人
association with Reddit going in, I hear you and you're right, there's a lot of toxicity on that website. But if you search hard enough and avoid the bad neighborhoods, you can find great little communities too. Well, I do. I have noticed the words. Yes. I also have noticed really nice communities. Yeah. Our subreddit is beautiful. I must say. Exactly. I like the, I like to, hang out in the blankies subreddit. And also just like the front pages really good. I'm, you know, that's an n people are funny. You'll find a lot of good stuff on there too. But it's duly noted, like, let, you know, just be careful out there, have your wits about you, and try to find the best information possible. So, right, well, thank you so much, Kurt. This is great. Yeah, anytime, Roman.
对Reddit有先入为主的负面联系，我懂你的意思，你是对的，那个网站上有很多有毒内容。但如果你努力寻找并避开不好的地方，你也能找到很棒的小社区。嗯，我是。我注意到了这些缺点。是的。我也注意到了非常nice的社区。是的。我们的板块很漂亮。我必须说。没错。我喜欢，我喜欢在blankies板块闲逛。而且就像首页真的很好。我，你知道，那是一个人们很搞笑的地方。你也会在上面找到很多好东西。但这一点已经被注意到了，就像，你知道，在外面要小心，保持清醒的头脑，并试着找到尽可能最好的信息。所以，好勒，非常感谢你，柯特。这太棒了。不客气，罗曼。
99% of his vote was produced this week by La Shaman Dawn, edited by Kelly Prime and executive produced by Delaney Hall, original music by Swan Rial. Sound mixed by Amidik Anatra, fact checking by Liz Boyd. Kurt Colstad is our digital director, Thorey Satim includes Vivian Le, Jason D'Leon, Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martin Gonzales, Jacob Moltenata Medina, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Such a thanks this week to Adam Rogers for being Adam Rogers and a warm welcome this week to our Fall Intern Olivia Green.
99%是由La Shaman Dawn于本周制作，凯利·普莱姆剪辑，德兰妮·霍尔执行制片，原创音乐由斯旺·里亚尔创作。混音由阿米迪克·安阿特拉完成，事实核查由莉兹·博伊德负责。柯特·科尔斯塔德是我们的数字总监，索里·萨蒂姆包括薇薇安·勒、杰森·德莱昂、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、马丁·冈萨雷斯、雅各布·莫尔特纳塔·梅迪纳、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。本周非常感谢亚当·罗杰斯成为亚当·罗杰斯，并热烈欢迎我们本周的秋季实习生奥利维亚·格林。
We are part of the Stitcher and Serious Exam Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org.
我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。现在总部设在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市住宅区以北六个街区处的潘多拉大楼。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，以及节目 @99PI org。
We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI. dot org. I love as well as every past episode of 99BI at 99bi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。你可以在99PI dot org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI过去的每一集节目。你也可以在99bi.org找到我喜欢的节目以及99BI的过去每一集。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。